alright so arrival's one of those movies
that I think will stick with people long
after they watch it dealing in hard
science Concepts this altered the
landscape of alien movies much in the
same way that Close Encounters of the
Third Kind did whereas in the past we'd
had films about aliens attacking earth
and blowing up the White House here a
rival does things differently to tell a
human story about life love and loss
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the entire film it's
ending and also talking about the hidden
details and things you missed in it
before touching on the movie though I
feel like we have to talk about the
short story that the entire thing's
based on titles story of your life this
work by Ted Chang deals with
inevitability set at the backdrop of
theoretical physics Ted went to see the
play Timeflies when you're alive and
this centers around a man having to deal
with an ocean that his wife's dying of
breast cancer at this point Ted came up
with the idea to tell a story about a
mother who had a daughter well aware
that the daughter was gonna die now the
short story is roughly 50 pages long and
it's packed with diagrams of sun beams
and also how light travels it's very
complicated and in-depth discussing how
predestination Works within the ideas of
Free Will in this story there's a line
that discusses how rare light has to
know where it will end up at so that it
can choose the point in which it fires
off from there's very much this idea in
space travel that you choose the
destination and then travel towards it
and thus all that's in between is
already predetermined and unchangeable
this is something that the film deals
with too and in it we follow linguist Dr
Louise Banks she's put in charge of
attempting to communicate with aliens
known as heptopods when we create
languages and sentence structures we
often take letters place them together
and then make The Words which we then
combine to form a sentence so that we
can get our point across thus we move
very much in a manner of point A to
point B where the heptopods differ
though is that they don't really speak
in sentences and instead they form the
entire idea and concept which is then
presented in a circular looking image
because of this they have completely
different ways of viewing reality and
thus they're able to see all time at
once pulling together both the past
present and future into one cohesive
moment now Luis does his too and
throughout the film we get what a
seemingly flashbacks of a daughter who
died at a very young age however this is
actually revealed to be the future with
Louise seeing her daughter's untimely
death in the original work she died when
she was in her mid-20s during an
accident but here they make it even more
heartbreaking by having her pass away as
a child her Ted Chang has given numerous
interviews about the movie in which he's
discussed the Big Bang entropy and how
time moves in general there are theories
that due to the big bang that
everything's already predetermined
because the entire universe set out from
this one point and then it traveled in
set directions thus creating set
outcomes the TV show devs did a great
job of explaining this and they used the
example of rolling a pen on a table he
said that if you roll it backwards then
that very much represents the past and
the journey that it's been on if you
rather forward we know what direction it
will go in because of where it's set out
from and thus we can predict the future
and determine where it will end up
before or it does applying this to a
grand scale means that everything's path
can be predicted because we know where
it starts out from and thus this cause
and effect is all predetermined there's
even ideas and signs that we only
remember things because of the big bang
and we're able to think back to Prior
moments because it all originates from
this point the notes we hear are the
same forwards and backwards so if you
play the music reversed it still all
sounds the same titled on the nature of
daylight we can't play this song in the
video for copyright reasons but the
entire thing can be found both forwards
and backwards on the internet from
official channels or even Louise's first
and last words to her daughter are
exactly the same come back to me come
back to me
Back To Me
Baby Come Back to Me
her name is also Hannah and Hannah
itself is of course a palindrome lots of
timey why me wibbly wobbly stuff that I
want to talk about more as we get
further in and I hope you're enjoying
the video so far and if you are please
hit that Thumbs Up Button now in this
short story they do something different
to the film and that has Louise actually
been able to change the events of the
future however she goes against this and
still decides to live out the life of
their child knowing that it's doomed to
end the way that it does this is
different to the movie as I never really
got the feeling that she has a choice
and instead she's living out the days
knowing that there's gonna be good and
bad ones either way I think there's
definitely a lot of Beauty in this as
she's still accepting her life and
spending the short time that she has
with her daughter because it's gonna
bring so much happiness I've just had
kids myself and I wouldn't trade the
time I've had with them for anything
else which I think is very much
reflected in Louise she knows that life
is precious and that just because
something is short it doesn't mean that
it means nothing I think this is very
much the opposite ideology to her
husband Ian in who's played by Jeremy
Renner the pair meet on the mission with
the hepsopods and he can't deal with the
fact that she still had a child knowing
that they would die one day because of
the pain it would cause I know some
people that simply won't get a dog
because they've already had one that
they ended up losing it's so
heartbreaking and the pain for Ian has
him wishing that she was never born in
the first place if it never happened he
could have been spared the fate of
losing his daughter which is described
as being the worst thing that a parent
can go through he sees it as a lost
whereas Louis sees it as a game even
though Hannah's life was very brief now
in the opening of the movie we panned
down from the lines of the ceiling in
Louise's home this is a shot that's
later mode at the 52 minute Mark when we
pan up from the ship's floor when
crafting the sets of arrival the
creative team deliberately put markings
in the ceilings and this can be seen in
the classroom and also on the ship when
discussing why this was done Danny
Villeneuve stated that he wanted these
to all resemble each other and that the
three settings could very much dictate
the past present future as we pan down
we see a giant window and later on in
the movie Louise stands in front of this
the director shot this with the idea
that we would also see repeated imagery
in this and later on we get a similar
shot on the ship the window itself is
meant to mirror The Divide between the
heptopods and Louise and even the trees
in the background are supposed to be
similar to the creatures now this
environment creates some familiarity
between her home and the ship and when
creating a dialogue between different
languages familiar environments are
often used as a way to find Common
Ground we cut a Louise holding her child
for the first time and this is reflected
in the moment to which we see her in the
same Hospital holding her for the final
one could have the pair playing out on
some grass and Louise moves her fingers
to resemble the heptopods whilst their
daughter also has a horse costume that
makes her look like she's riding one
this was done deliberately as is eight
legs in total reflecting how the
creatures themselves carry this too the
heptopods themselves are covered in a
thick fog and Judo is not really being
able to see where they come from they do
look like hands sticking down through
the smoke it's almost like they're
connected to Arms in a body that we
can't see the invasive I've always
thought this was meant to make them act
almost like the hands of God to me they
kind of look like the aliens from The
Simpsons but we'll not get into that at
any Villeneuve also wanted to give them
a look like the Grim Reaper which would
make Humanity fear that they've brought
death with them in the source material
they were called raspberry and flapper
Raz in the film they're called Abba and
Costello these comedians did the who's
on first sketch which centered around
two people that constantly
miscommunicated with each other similar
to what we see in the movie Abbott is
later killed and we rarely see him
interacting with the humans because of
this exact reason whether the heptopods
are very much a species based around
unity and coming together for the
greater good this is why Abbott doesn't
mind sacrificing himself though he of
course worries about it Abid shows up
late just before his death and he was
likely preparing himself for it which is
why he turned up after Castello Costello
flies away and this is because he has to
be there for Louise in order to have the
conversation with her after the event
plays out in the movie the military
actually state that the pair aren't
communicating with each other and they
wouldn't need to be because they already
know the past and future they are very
much all together as one and even their
mission is to bring Humanity together
through a universal language that will
make a sea life differently they want us
to do this so that in 3000 years they
can return and we can help them out the
entire movie is about coming together
you also see Hannah's life including all
the ups and downs
I hate you
now we see the scene in which the lump
is found and even though Louise knows
this it's still heartbreaking because
the moment is finally upon her Hannah's
death is inevitable and we see it
playing out before we catch up to Louise
walking down a circular Corridor this
was deliberately chosen to match the
idea that time is cyclical and circular
things are something that repeats
throughout the movie the languages of
course presented using circles some with
time no longer being something with a
beginning middle and end it instead
loops around the feature affects the
past just as much as the past affects
the future the line that follows this
even touches upon it
but now I'm not so sure I believe in
beginnings and endings
preceding this we can also hear who he's
saying and this was the end
I know this shot happens early on in the
movie This is actually the last scene in
terms of the story if it's being told in
chronological order it's all sort of
looping around which is shown here at
this circular location is later mirrored
when Louise meets General Shang he gives
information that she needs to use in the
past and this all happens at a Place Des
arts in Montreal which is also secular
Eloise also wears circular spiral
earrings again tying into this notion
then he also wanted to make the haptopod
ship secular but they felt it was a bit
too on the nose so they elongated it to
make it like a contact lens this is
actually also based on an asteroid as
well which is why it has a stone's
surface now even the music itself is
based around the circle of fits and an
interval known as the perfect fifth this
is created by placing multiple bits
together and in the end it gives you a
cyclical Melody now Louise looks
depressed and lonely when we first see
her which I think we're meant to assume
is because of her daughter's death
however we learned that she's okay and
is probably just looking down because
she saw Jared posted a video or
something and this is the day that the
heptopods arrived and we learned that 12
showed up on the planet at key locations
I'm sorry Jared I love you really now in
the short story there was 112 I think
right and I might be reaching but I
think they chose 12 for a reason the
movie is obviously dealing with time and
clock set 12 points on them which also
forms a circle might be reading into
that but the school is evacuated and
humanity is sent into a panic Louise
quickly rushes out of the room leaving
the TV on a nice bit of continuity she
returns the next day and is still out in
the open because she never had time to
close it the heptopods are meant to
bring us together but it's actually
pushed us apart due to the world being
divided Nations all refused to speak to
each other I love how this idea of
communication or lack thereof sounding
laced throughout every aspect of the
film not only do we see this in the
heptopods and Louise but we also see
between Louise and Ian when she refuses
to tell film about Hannah now on the
news we see a report from Montana in
which the reporter says this eight hours
after landing there's still no signs of
what might be called First Contact might
be a reach but this was the site of
first Contact in Star Trek first Contact
now the ships never touched down on
Earth and this was done for a specific
reason Dany acknowledged some might find
it where they travel trillions of light
years but never landed however they
wanted Humanity to make the final steps
themselves this is why they float in the
air and why we very much have to go to
them military then come in with Colonel
Weber who's played by Forest Whitaker
due to working on insurgents in the war
in the Middle East Louise has top level
clearance and he needs her because she's
the best of the best of the best sir he
plays the tape of someone talking back
and forth with the heptopods and later
on we see a body being wheeled out when
she makes it to the base this was likely
the previous translator and this is why
Weber says you're better than Alaska
a screenwriter Eric hyzera was also
working on bird box at the time and huge
hit out so they're now playing podcasts
for saying that he might have used ideas
from that in that the planets swarmed by
things that overwhelm the human mind so
much that people can't comprehend
looking at them which may be something
that's too modern how he dies with the
heptibods who's being a
carted off in the Medevac not everyone
is able to process experiences like this
the judging by that he luckily had the
same dreams that we see Louise having
when she started to understand the
language he'd see his own death know it
was fast approaching unless in turn it
would likely lead to his own death a
sinus have discovered that learning a
new language literally rewires the brain
to think certain ways and with the
heptopods it allows Luis to see her
entire life it completely Alters her
perspective of time and it goes from
being linear to non-linear so things
like the past present and future no
longer exists if you've seen Watchmen
then you basically become like Dr
Manhattan which means that Louise can
see her daughter again but it would have
to be in the past which is why she says
come back to me however in the moment of
her death it's still extremely
heartbreaking and that comes with it
disgrace that Hannah Khan experience
time like she can so she's truly gone it
said that once you dream in another
language that you start to truly
understand it and the movie's littered
with long air more thoroughly detailed
visions of Hannah's Louise starts to
comprehend it more Eric all this data
that originally the aliens were going to
give us blueprints for an Interstellar
ship but after seeing Christopher
Nolan's movie he decided to change
things up also right out of interstellar
on the channel right now and we learn
Weber's going to another translator and
she says
before you commit to him
ask him the Sanskrit word for war and
its translation he later shows up and
says that he said the word meant an
argument whereas Louise says that it
actually means a desire for More Cows
this is a throwaway line but it actually
has a lot of importance later on the
word till gets miscommunicated and thus
people think the heptopods are talking
about weapons one could be War as an
argument whilst another could view it as
a desire for More Cows and this language
is very dependent on context and also
intent China almost starts a war because
Humanity gets a word and this could be
interpreted as meaning a weapon this
later expanded to say there is no time
use weapon which is taken as a threat
however the word weapon in context is
the main key thing here they're saying
there's no time because they don't view
time as a thing and they're attempting
to pass on this knowledge to humanity so
use weapon becomes use the tool this is
the tool of language that they're trying
to teach and it shows how one little
thing can spiral out of control also
interesting to see Russia you're in
China making allegiances on the TV maybe
history just repeats itself and we're
all going through the motions anyway
Weber picks up Louise in a helicopter
which is where she meets her future
husband again there's this idea of
miscommunication as she doesn't have
headphones on when he first speaks and
no she can't hear him when she puts them
on he says oh the Cornerstone of
civilization isn't language science
no basically disagrees with everything
in her book that says language is the
first thing we should develop however
the entire headphone thing that happened
moments before completely disproves this
language is what he tried to use to
speak to Louise first and then science
was brought in through the technology
and the headphones now they approached
the ship and I love this shot with a
cloud strolling in the CGI in this
film's astounding especially for the 50
million dollar budget that it had and
nothing feels wrong or out of place
instead it all crafts this world in
order to give us the idea that something
like this could happen tomorrow now the
look of the movie is actually inspired
by the art of Martin hovland England
this is dark and dreary and Denise
stated that he wanted the whole movie to
feel like a damn Tuesday morning bus
ride which now you mention it mate I can
see it nanomian films dealing with
Aliens the movie skips over language and
just lets everyone understand everyone
this is normally done through Universal
translator or in cases like Star Wars
characters icon can already speak haties
so he can understand Jabba the movie
really makes you think about how
difficult it would actually be to try
and start up a dialogue with an alien
and had a completely different term of
reference to what we have on Earth
language is a massive barrier and we've
even seen in our own history how
miscommunication has led to death in war
we watch as the English-speaking
countries like Australia don't mind
sharing information but the ones where
English isn't predominant definitely
hold things back now they suit up and
head to the ship and we can see how
clunky they are when Louise leaves the
tent the shape has lower gravity to our
Earth and when they're all on it the
hazmat suits are actually CGI this was
done so that the actors could act like
they were in a lower gravity environment
without the restrictions of movement
that they'd normally provide they
touched the bottom of the ship which is
made out of stone and to me this has
been chosen for a specific reason the
phrase written in stone of course means
that something can't be changed whereas
metal can be welded this structure gives
the idea that everything is unchangeable
they travel up into it and in a nice bit
of detail we can see the risk devices
moving from portrait to land Escape mode
this is happening as the gravity
reorientates around them so that they
can walk on the walls or the floors now
they place a bird on the ground and this
was a practice carried out by coal
miners which led to the phrase a canary
and a coal mine dangerous gases like
carbon monoxide would kill the canary
quite quickly and thus this would let
miners know that they had to leave the
area immediately they end up going back
and as Donny takes off his suit we can
see it almost forming a yin and yang
symbol yin and yang is of course a
circle that has circles within it but it
also has balance this is a theme
throughout the movie with everything
trying to act in harmony at the hour 37
Mark we see Louise unpacking her buck in
the future this also has a black and
white circle on the cover similar to a
yin and yang symbol huge adapts to
makeshift quilt on Reddit for spotting
that and from here we watch Louise
obsessing over the language the planet
starts to destabilize so we see on the
news that looting starting happen across
the entire world religious groups say
that their arrival is ushered in the
prophecy of the end of the world and
again I'm gonna take it back to this
idea of miscommunication because the
government aren't being transparent
because of this people can run wild with
Theory times leads to more panic and
confusion if the government would just
speak to people they'd quell the
paranoia but instead they don't which
causes people to live in fear this is
something that's of course reflected in
the movie later on with the word weapon
causing a rogue faction of humans to
attack this also happened in contact as
well which I think that this movie has
taken some inspiration from are using a
whiteboard Louise tells them the word
for human and they create their own
response on their own whiteboard however
Weber is worried that this might not be
helping and Louise tells him the story
of James Kirk and when he went to
Australia they pointed at an animal to
ask what it was the Aborigines replied
by saying kangaroo it was only later
they learned that this meant I don't
know and this idea of misunderstanding
is of course reflected in the term
weapon now it's a great story but as
Louise says it's made up it was in the
short story though and I view its
inclusion to show how language can be
used to manipulate other people Weber
says we all know what happened to the
Aborigines and it's clear that the story
might actually push him into the corner
to fear what's going on now in case you
don't know there could very much be a
hidden Invasion going on in the film
that takes us into things three times
hidden Invasion time during the movie
might not be true I read it bloody red a
scene on there from a user that this
might actually be an alien invasion
hidden under our nose when we look at
our own history there's been several
times where Britain's entered a country
propped up their language in religion
and they've become the ruling power this
is very much what the heptopods are
doing and they're showing us a
completely new way of thinking that
replaces our own this would change our
language and way of being and I've even
seen discussions that this could be a
metaphor for communism with them making
everyone a collective this takes away
their individuality and though I don't
think that's the intention of the film
at all I do think that's an
interpretation that's worth going over
anyway shut up just shut up and that's
the NFL you
[Music]
anyway within China is viewing the ships
as hostile and that they've launched
warships this is led by General Shang
who Louise ends up speaking to later on
in the future she learns of what his
wife said to him on her deathbed and in
the past she uses this when calling him
to get him to listen it shows how the
future has an impact on the past and
it's through this new way of seeing
things that she can save us zabad and
Costello Louise and Hannah and of course
a general and his wife death is
something that unites us all and it's
through this that we're able to
appreciate life and avoid death at all
costs Louise writes on the Whiteboard to
explain what question they want to pose
and she's very much using this as a
concept to explain to Weber much like
how she does to the aliens although this
repetition of every side having
breakdowns in language and adds so much
depth to the movie Louise ends up taking
the suit off and risking the atmosphere
in order to speak to the aliens directly
and this furthers the communication
after doing this she has her first
vision of Hannah showing how immersing
yourself in a language can get you to
think differently later on Luis steps
into a vessel this takes her behind the
glass locate in the ship this exposes
her directly to the heptopod's
atmosphere and there is a throwaway line
in the movie about radiation levels she
coughs upon entering and it's probably
not a safe environment for a human to be
in when looking over theories for the
film I've seen some state that this
could end up being what causes the
cancer in her child but it's to
sacrifice Louise has to do in order to
bridge the gap between the species we
see a soldier on the phone speaking to
his partner and she's clearly panicking
that the aliens are going to kill him he
says things like you don't need to worry
but this isn't enough and it
demonstrates a panic that exists again
there's this breakdown in communication
which causes people's minds to wander he
himself also isn't being told anything
and later on we see several news reports
in YouTube videos grifting about
misinformation this is to get people
angry and look we've all lived through
the last two years and I think the movie
is clearly pointing out that in times of
not knowing there will be those that see
an opportunity to build an audience and
thus make money this later in spies to
Soldier to attack the ship showing how
people that do this cause real world
consequences by spreading ignorance and
fear the movie doesn't pick sides though
and instead it says about the mainstream
media and independent ones can be used
to stoke division which is why you
should subscribe to the Kevin spoilers
show shabao if they're scientists they
don't seem to ask a lot of questions
obviously this is because they already
know everything and therefore don't need
to learn anything from us we then get a
shot of the 12 locations where they've
shown up the last one is of hakito which
could be a reference to contact in that
we discover there was a secret launch
site after the first one was destroyed
which allowed Humanity to continue its
Journey Into The Stars spoiler alert
we see that code is used to decipher the
language and this is a real world
program called World from Mathematica it
allows for machine learning and complex
symbols to be created which studies a
language the movie version has been
changed slightly so I can perform what's
being shown on screen and these parts
were actually written by Christopher
Wolfram who is the code Creator's son
the language is a palindrome as well and
it's the same forward as it is backwards
they know the entire concept and idea
that they want to present and how much
space it needs to occupy and thus
they're able to show to us we then get a
flash of Hannah discussing her parents
and she's done a drawing of them talking
to animals this is the first clue that
she's in the future where the animals of
course representing the aliens we later
see this picture in full with it having
a canary in a cage and the animals being
made out of Play-Doh to represent the
heptopods she then has a vision of a
haptipod standing in the corner of a
room might be a reach but this also
reminded me a lot of the spider shot
that's in Denise film enemy now we
discover that a game is being used to
converse with the heptopods and this is
in places that are beginning to view
them as enemies games are of course
competitive and thus they create divides
with both winners and losers the Hep
departs are about coming together but
games are the opposite to this and thus
this is why these sides end up
escalating their feelings to attack
Louisiana then ended up heading on board
the ship but the explosive has already
been planted Abbott has to remained
behind so he can force the pair out and
thus he sacrifices himself for the
greater good Louise and Ian are saved
and in his final moments Abbott leaves
behind thousands of spirals that carry a
lot of information with them this
contains everything they know oh we'll
ever know and though it will take years
to decipher it's enough to ensure
Humanity will live for another 3000
years without destroying itself the ship
ascends further into the sky and China
escalate their threats to say that if
the aliens don't leave within 24 hours
that they're gonna be fired upon
Communications between nations has
ceased and it seems like we're all
doomed we get another Flash Forward of
Hannah who asks a mother to explain what
win-win situation is using scientific
terms she says if you want science call
your father now Ian is obviously a
scientist hitting at the reveal later on
he studied the message and also measured
it and it divides perfectly into 1 12.
all of the ships have their own messages
that will come together but Humanity has
to work as a whole in order to unlock it
all he says that in order to get
everyone to work together that the U.S
should give up their knowledge first
which Ian says is a non-zero sum game
this ties back to the win-win scene and
Louise uses this term in the future to
tell Hannah the correct phrase
non-zero-sum game
that's it yeah
of course told to her by Ian who is
Hannah's father showing how he was the
one who could describe it using
scientific phrasing the aliens then send
out their own vessel which Louise goes
into this is her finally seeing the
creatures and the smoke itself was also
its own form of miscommunication as we
couldn't fully see them this created
barriers between the two sides but here
Louise gets to have a face-to-face
conversation she asks questions like who
is Hannah and finally learns the truth
she's dropped back on Earth and we get
another flash of her daughter she asks
why her father left and we learned that
Louise told him about her incoming death
Ian muser is making the wrong choice and
to him he'd rather avoid the pain at all
cost the ships then change position and
the country start to mount their
military we get flashes of Louise's
Burke in which he's understood the
language and we can see her teaching
this in the future Louise is told by
Weber that it's over and they're lifting
off in five minutes finally she realizes
what she has to do and in the future we
see her at a gala this has a happy
depart's flag hanging up alongside the
other nations showing how we've all
United together now their flag is a
black and white circle which again ties
into the Notions of Yin and Yang there
are no Shades of Gray because everything
is clear and all is known instead of
there being different interpretations
she speaks with General Shang who tells
her that she reached out to him on his
private number Louise doesn't know what
he's talking about but he shows her his
phone and then confirms that she called
him which she then goes and does in the
past he tells her the last words his
wife said to him which he kept to
himself again taimi why me whibley you
know by now and when she calls him this
de-escalates everything and the ship
seem to vanish in a thin air which the
humans can't understand however these
are four-dimensional beings that don't
perceive time in the same way that we do
because of this they can travel back and
forth between what we're unable to
perceive therefore they don't really
disappear they just move through time
and they're no longer in the position
that they were when we could first see
them for example if you leave a football
Bowl outside for a month it was in that
position for a month however if you move
it in the next month it's now gone from
that position the person that you were
the month prior wouldn't have been able
to perceive this movement though because
it hasn't happened yet from their
perspective it does change position
eventually though and if you'd in a
non-linear fashion we can understand
where events you went to but we once
more get a repeat of the start of the
movie with us panning down from the
ceiling of Louise's home she pours out a
wine glass and in the shot at the start
of the movie we could see two which was
one for her and one for Ian she says
that the day the ships left was the day
Hannah's story began and we see a
blossoming romance between her and Ian
back and Montana in the future she walks
to the window and we catch Ian out on
the grass Louise ends up knocking on it
to communicate with him and this is also
summing that the heptopods did now at
this point Louise decides to embrace
about the good and bad like the ray of
light that knows where it wants to go
she knows what she has to go through to
get there and the end of the journey she
accepts her life for all that it is and
decides to embrace it instead of fearing
the loss Ian says it wasn't meeting the
heptopods that meant the most to him and
instead it was actually meeting Louise
perhaps one day he might see why she did
what she did and though she knows the
future will be painful she wants to go
through with it she hugs him in both the
past and present and says that she
forgot how good it felt to be held by
him you can see the pain on her face
knowing what she's about to go through
and Ian asks her at her home if she
wants to make a baby it's going to tear
her heart out having to lose Hannah but
in the end she still wants to do it the
movie closes out with her saying yes yes
[Music]
yeah if that doesn't have you tearing up
then I don't know what will and that
closes out both the movie and our
breakdown and I hope you enjoyed going
back to it I'd of course love to hear
your thoughts on it and if there's
anything we missed then make sure you
leave it below huge thank you for all
your support on these older movie
breakdowns and if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our one for Shutter Island there's
so many layers to the film and we go
through them all bit by bit to talk
about why it works so well that will be
linked on screen right now and with that
out of the way I've been Paul you've
been the best I'll see you next one take
care peace